in our continuing coverage about tech
coming back to work
and the pandemic eventually ending which
we're all hoping for i am so frustrated
about this delta variant
my god we could have had everybody back
to work we could have
been opening up society and some
percentage of you
have opted out of getting the vaccine
and have opted to get the delta variant
there's new information out there for
you the delta variant is
massively more massively massively more
contagious
you're not going to avoid getting covet
if you're not vaccinating all likelihood
you're either going to get vaccinated
and maybe get a light case of the delta
variant
or you're definitely going to get delta
varying that seems to be the case here
please please
if you're hearing my voice just think
about do you want to have this argument
about lockdowns and arguments about
masks for the next year
or the next six months all we have to do
is get another 10
of the people hearing my voice maybe 20
depending on the neighborhood or the
town you live in if just another 10
20 percent of y'all who have been
holding out get the vaccine
this is gonna end and we can have
parties and go to vegas and go to
concerts again and go to sporting arenas
who the heck wants to be in a perpetual
state of arguing over lockdowns and
masks and carrions fighting about mass
or no miss
i don't care if you didn't take the
vaccine before
i'm just asking right now if you're an
anti-vaxxer or you've been avoiding it
just look at the new data and just take
some fresh eyes
and investigate it because now there's a
billion people on the planet who've
gotten these vaccines if there was a
problem with them i think we would know
by now don't you think and do you think
the risk of
the delta variant which is highly
contagious
and spreading like wildfire what if that
was spreading like wildfire and it was
three times as
lethal well that's a possibility right
these things mutate so take this as a
public service announcement
and let's talk about going back to work
because this now the delta variant has
given everybody who doesn't want to go
back to work
or anybody who doesn't want to go back
and be a teacher
the ability to say you know what i don't
feel safe i don't want to go back to
work
well you know what now this is
escalating people are going to be asked
to wear vaccine buttons
to prove they're vaccinated they're
going to start asking for vaccine cards
when you go to restaurants and movie
theaters
and sporting events like they did at the
knicks game when i watched my knicks
uh go to the first round of playoffs for
the first decade
they're going to be you're basically by
not getting the vaccine and by extending
this
we're just going to create even more
chaos in society and here we go
uh sundar pachai told employees in a
note wednesday that the mountain view
california-based company would begin
requiring anyone on its us campuses to
be vaccinated in the coming weeks
he said google will expand that
requirement to other countries in future
months
google is planning on returning to work
in mid-october they were going to do
september
and he mentioned on twitter and google
expects employees back in the office
three days a week on average
so you're going to be required if you're
working in certain jobs if you're going
to certain sporting events you're going
to be required to get
this vaccine and so
i think maybe take a look into it take a
deep look
and these companies i think are
benefiting from work from home so i
don't think work from home is going away
i think it's going to be a very flexible
environment for the next couple of years
and google has joined morgan stanley
united airlines black rock and other
companies
who have either banned unvaccinated
employees from their offices
or required them to be vaccinated and
that's by course at work
uh we spoke about vaccine passports and
private companies requiring vaccines in
order to return back to work on all in
episode 40 and 41
and people were complaining about those
two episodes hey we're talking about
this too much well
you know if you're in business or you're
covering the markets
and or you're in politics like we need
to end this
pandemic and get it down to under 100
debts a day
under 10 000 cases a day and guess what
we were at that level
a month ago in the beginning of july we
were below
you know i think we're 11 000 cases on
average 30 days ago now we're back up to
50.
we were at like some days 150 people die
in the united states who knows how many
of them were dying with covet as opposed
to dying from covet
who knows how many of them were uh you
know end of life so
they weren't dying with the majority of
their life ahead of them they might have
died a couple of years earlier obviously
still tragic but
we had this thing beat folks and now
we're going to have to get into a war
with our employees and getting on planes
and with each other
are you massed are you vaxxed let's stop
this annoying thing and move back
to solving bigger problems in the world
like global warming and making sure
everybody has a great education and
health care for everybody please
reconsider if
you have put off getting a vaccine or
the second shot because the second shot
i understand
is critical what's going to happen to
unvaccinate employees well
in tech we need employees and if you're
unvaccinated you're going to be
working from home if you're an
exceptional employee that's great but if
you don't come to the office
in a company that's a hybrid company i
do think if you're not in the office
with the locus of power and the top
executives you're probably going to be
uh throttling your career advancement
and not intentionally it's just going to
be harder to advance it doesn't mean you
won't advance
but you can imagine if you're sitting
next to zuckerberg or you're
sitting next to bezos or whoever the new
ceo
of amazon is you know you're going to go
further if you're on the campus you're
just going to go further
faster and with less effort it's going
to just be easier to go further in your
career because you'll have built those
relationships and when a new opportunity
comes up is the new opportunity think
about a manager
or a ceo of a big company new
opportunity comes out we're going to do
ar glasses vr glasses we're starting a
car division in apple
are they going to give it to somebody
who's working from you know some lake
lake cuomo or something you know this
person's on the amalfi coast on a
different time zone
you're not putting that person in charge
of it great that person gets to live on
the amalfi coast
amazing but they're not going to get to
advance their career and have the most
interesting work so if you care about
the most interesting work in the world
and you want to be near the locust power
and you don't want to have to get
covered and you want to stop arguing
with people
and you want to go to sporting events
and have musicians go on tour again
and we get to go to concerts oh my lord
or a broadway show
let's just all get vaccinated not all of
us just 10
more please do it please reconsider
too many small business owners are
busier than ever
it is crazy out there things are growing
like gangbusters but
since they're focused on managing and
growing their businesses they can't
always spend the time they need to
on recruiting the most important part of
running your company
that's why linkedin jobs has made it
easier to find and hire
the best candidates for free you can get
started by posting your job for free
to reach linkedin's network of 740
million professionals fill out targeted
screening questions to get your role
in front of the most qualified
candidates with the experience skills
and motivation you need
then it's easy to filter and prioritize
the top candidates
you'd like to interview so easy using
linkedin's
software we love linkedin jobs here at
launch and in 2021 we've hired a second
producer
a curriculum designer and a few more
researchers all through linkedin jobs
we love it it's easy your job is going
to get in front of the right person and
you might find
that game changer that unicorn that will
change everything at your company and
boy
is it amazing you know in that feeling
when you find somebody who's a really
great contributor
well you can have that feeling right now
because every week
nearly 40 million job seekers visit
linkedin
post your first job for free at
linkedin.com
unicorn that's right your first job is
free linkedin.com slash unicorn
u-n-i-c-o-r-n you have to play unicorn
that's linkedin.com
unicorn to post your first job for free
terms and conditions apply because
they're giving you something for free